cigarette smoking is the number one
cause of preventable death in America
killing 500,000 people each year vaping
claims to be a safer alternative and
with 72% of all vapes sold being the
sleek new Joule vapes what exactly is
the difference between smoking and joy
smoking a cigarette involves a narrow
cylinder of paper filled with tobacco
the filter is made of hairlike fibers
meant to trap some of the bad smoke
unfortunately one study found smoking
with the filter actually made people
inhale harder pulling in more harmful
chemicals a joule is an electronic
cigarette designed to look like a flash
drive and is charged in a USB port it
has two components one contains the
battery and the system that regulates
the temperature the other is a cartridge
full of an e liquid which also acts as
the mouthpiece these are called drool
pods and can be switched out or replaced
when they are empty in Canada for
example a single pack of Marlboro
cigarettes costs around $13 which
consists of 20 cigarettes a jewel pod
which has similar nicotine content to a
pack of cigarettes cost $16 and gives
you roughly 200 puffs
therefore drooling is more expensive but
as are most things that claim to be
healthier so let's get into what is in a
cigarette versus a jewel pod the main
ingredient in cigarettes is cured
tobacco leaves but also recycled stems
stocks and floor sweepings known as
sheet tobacco companies have added
hundreds of ingredients to improve taste
decrease harshness and increase
absorption some examples are sugars for
taste menthol to numb the throat and
ammonia to increase nicotine absorption
in your lungs
studies show that depending on the
cigarette there are either hundreds to
thousands of ingredients of which many
are proven to cause cancer cigarettes
involve combustion and burn at a
temperature between 400 to 700 degrees
Celsius meaning you inhale carbon
monoxide poly aromatic hydrocarbons and
nitric oxide all of which are dangerous
toxins drooling on the other hand does
not involve consumption of the tobacco
plant the creators of drool found that
by adding benzoic acid to just the
nicotine salts in tobacco they could
mimic a cigarettes rapid nicotine
unlike cigarettes drool eliquid only
consists of five ingredients which are
benzoic acid a nicotine solution blister
all propylene glycol and food grade
flavoring other vape companies may use
the chemical diacetyl for flavoring
which can cause dangerous lung
inflammation but julik sap oint to not
include this chemical the temperature
needs to be at least 150 degrees Celsius
to create an inhalable aerosol therefore
there is no combustion reaction which
means decreased toxins for now science
says that drooling is healthier than
smoking but they both involve
consumption of a similar amount of a
mind-altering drug whether you smoke or
jewel you are inhaling nicotine into
your chest where it passes through the
thin membrane of your lungs and into
your bloodstream from there the nicotine
is carried to the brain and within
seconds it binds to neurons in the
reward pathway of your brain this is the
part of the brain that evolved to make
you feel good after doing biologically
important things like eating or
exercising the inhaled nicotine cheats
the system by fitting right into the
receptors in this pathway causing the
release of a neurotransmitter called
dopamine
this causes the cigarette you smoked or
the Joule you vaped to make you feel
good
satisfied and happy nicotine can wake
you up if sleepy or calm you down
if stressed so it is no wonder nicotine
is extremely addictive the popularity of
drooling amongst young people means less
are smoking cigarettes which some
epidemiologists think is a good thing
however drooling is also very new which
means there is no long term studies to
uncover any hidden negative effects the
best thing you can do right now for your
health is to skip nicotine products all
together if you want to know even more
about drooling we just uploaded the
newest episode of our podcast sidenote
to youtube where we talk about the new
FDA regulations our first time smoking
and scientifically debate whether or not
we think drooling is good click here to
listen on YouTube or subscribe to side
note wherever you get your podcasts